Zelda theories and Zelda lore can get a
little dull sometimes no I'm not saying
it's boring at all but sometimes we ABBA
Zelda community can get so caught up
with what this means for that person or
who made what relic and what game comes
where in the timeline etc etc that we
forget sometimes just how enjoyable
simply playing The Legend of Zelda is
and one of the reasons why this
franchise is so loved and enjoyable to
sit down and play is it's jolly sense of
humor so in this video I'm going to
cover the 5 funniest characters across
the entire series and spoiler alert this
is all my opinion oh I know what a
concept but if you agree or disagree or
have other characters that are funnier
to you let me know in the comments below
this list is only gonna have 5 or so
entries so chances are I'm gonna miss
some fan favorites out there also one
last tiny thing before we get into the
list on any given list covering the
funniest or weirdest Zelda characters
there's a certain individual that is
basically guaranteed to stand out above
the rest by a good margin and that would
be none other than ferryman himself
tingle not only is tingle a very weird
very funny-looking a person but he's the
most weird and the most funny and so I
think he's more so on his own tier of
weirdness and funniness kind of given so
he's not gonna be on this list anyway I
think that's all I wanted to go over so
without further ado bring on the funny
first up on the list we have Niko from
the Wind Waker this tiny little man is a
member of the dreaded pirate crew known
as Tetris pirate crew calling him
funny-looking is kind of a given because
not only is he short and I mean short
like shorter than link who is already
just a child in this game but he also
kind of rocks this one tooth look I mean
I'm sure he gets all the ladies with
that pearly white tooth just taken out
there but because this little guy is so
little and helpless looking he's always
tasked with the laundry and cleaning and
other menial tasks that none of the
other superior pirates bother doing
which is why he's so happy when link
decides to join up and temporarily
become a pirate he calls link his new
swabby and immediately rejoices that
he's no longer at the
the food chain poor little guy in his
first task for link he challenges the
young hero to a jumping and swinging
game that he's apparently come up with
while being alone down here thinking
there's no way link could complete it so
quickly which of course he does but the
funniest part about this little game is
when he's showing link how to do it I
mean yes it does seem like it would be
kind of challenging in real life but
just listening to Niko try to chill he's
just trying so hard oh man
later on in the game slight spoiler
warning here by the way after link
leaves the Pirates and tries to sneak on
their ship on windfall island at
nightfall
guess who got left behind in the ship
while all the other pirates got to spend
one night celebrating on shore yup poor
little Niko who is back inevitably at
the bottom of the food chain
he has another harder swinging challenge
for you which of course he beaten he
rewards you for but these few
interactions with the great Niko have
proven to be some of the most funny and
memorable across the whole franchise
next up we have the one and only
masterful traveling salesman himself
beetle well saying the one and only
feels kind of weird since he's present
in Wind Waker Skyward Sword breath of
the wild and other games so even though
all beetles are hilarious I'm
specifically referring to the one from
Skyward Sword this absolute legend of a
man can be found flying over Skyloft
yes flying his shop is flying you have
to ring a bell for him to drop a rope
for link to grab on to and be pulled up
to sea beetle and his wares and then
it's revealed to you exactly what is
powering beetles flying shop that would
be beetle himself pedaling infinitely
all day long I mean don't get me wrong
of course I'm jealous of all his gains
in those
legs and rock-hard abs but when you ask
him why he's pedaling he explains that
he's being eco-friendly eco-friendly you
know what's more eco-friendly than a
flying shop a regular one sitting on the
ground this is also the most terrifying
iteration of beetle because if you make
the mistake of perusing his items for
sale but then leaving with no intention
of buying anything oh he takes that
personally because you see since he's
such a noble eco-friendly soul pedaling
all day to keep his little air shop in
the air when a customer board said shop
it increases the weight and Beatle ends
up having to pedal even harder and when
said customer namely link decides to
leave without even buying anything
Beatle decides to literally drop them
out of his airship with a little
trapdoor he installed just for that
reason and when he does he looks at you
with this little smile like he gets some
joy from ejecting you downwards towards
the ground this may even be worse than
the Luigi death stare from Mario Cart
this is count his murderous intent I
mean he has no way of knowing whether
you're going to survive the fall but
either way his weird and somewhat
terrifying presence and skyward sword
makes for funny character number 4 on my
list number 3 brings us to a very
familiar face for some and a complete
stranger for others Princess Ruto of
ocarina of time sure she eventually
becomes a sage which is closer to being
boring than funny but when she and Link
are both children is what I'm talking
about
for most people having to deal with her
throughout jabu jabu's belly is rather
annoying but looking back at it it's
actually pretty funny I mean here you
have a little princess girl who is such
a brat that she refuses simply refuses
to walk on her own and demands that link
carry her around on his head I mean
which ends up making the dungeon
possible but still this girl this girl
is crazy
she also flat-out blatantly lies and
says she did not write the letter in a
bottle that link found in lake hylia
which was signed princess route oh and
after young Lincoln the princess clear
the dungeon well I suppose she develops
a bit of a crush on the youthful hero
and this ensues
[Music]
just look at her face swimming up to
linked got one thing on the mind
she then tricks him into getting engaged
by giving him the Zora sapphire which
she calls the Sora's engagement ring
I mean these kids are what 9 10 years
old already engaged gang that's some
serious a game right there but linked
bless his heart is pretty clueless as to
what she means by all of this there
isn't really any evidence to show that
the two ever ended up together
especially if you believe in these sages
are dead theory but looking back on her
entire encounter she's pretty clearly a
very funny part of Ocarina of Time
number two brings us to Kakariko village
of Twilight Princess meet thorns the
bomb shop owner Barnes is probably the
most cowardly character in the entire
game and has plenty of screen time and
cut scenes to show off that funny little
characteristic of his but aside from his
undying love of self protection and his
goggle glasses belly shirt high-heeled
boots and welding mask that he never
takes off this guy runs a bomb shop by
himself that has both a buying and
returning counter as two separate
counters but how does he accomplish this
if he's the only employee of Barnes Bomb
shop by literally running back and forth
between the two and kept this pretending
to be two different people instead of
just I don't know processing both kinds
of transactions at the same counter what
is it with the Zelda franchise and Corky
salespeople is there a normal sales
person in any of the games you can't
help but like Barnes though because even
though he's a cowardly strange-looking
single dude he helps to alleviate the
darker theme of the game by giving
players plenty of physical humor before
we get to the final funny character I
have a couple honorable mentions too you
know mentioned groups from Skyward Sword
is a pretty funny character who rapidly
became a fan favorite once the game
released he's in constant competition
with link over the affections of the
fair Zelda and even follows link to the
surface landing on him in the process
they both survive though so you know no
harm done in breath of the wild bowls
ins confetti throwing at the marriage of
his employee hudson always makes me
laugh to that end his
anyway of course there are more funny
characters scattered throughout the
games but that's all the mentions I'll
give in this video the final funniest
character from The Legend of Zelda
series takes us back again to the Wind
Waker at two different times in the game
you'll run into not a shelf owner but a
man who runs mini games while absolutely
hating his job meet Salvatore
unexpectedly successful yet extremely
depressed entrepreneur this guy is a
one-man team that runs all aspects of
the games he's created from sound
effects to gameplay the thing is what he
really wants to do is become a famous
painter which so far isn't faring out
for him so well so the poor guy came up
with his current hugely successful
business plan of creating fun minigames
and is completely bored of it all
leading to one of the funniest
characters ever made the games he
created include different characters and
storylines all of which he demonstrates
by himself
he puts on different masks and will
alter his voice to become the other
characters in his games even characters
of the opposite gender like tetra and
even makes his own sound effects like
this one it's amazing you know part of
me wishes I could just sit down and come
up with as successful a business as he
did but who knows maybe I just end up
depressed like him he ultimately doesn't
matter much to the story of Wind Waker
but is a necessary encounter for those
who like to get all heart containers and
treasure maps for instance but when you
run across him you're sure to never
forget the sploosh and that wraps it up
thank you so much for watching let me
know in the comments who your funniest
character is or if you agree with my
list and if you want to see more videos
like this one be sure to LIKE and
subscribe if you haven't already for
much more juicy zelda content to come as
always huge thank you to my faithful
patrons including the newest member kill
Lily the only thing that maps out
correctly if you're interested in a
shout out and your name at the end of
all my videos check out the link in the
description below also down there are
links to my Twitter and discord so feel
free to connect with me there if you'd
like that's all I've got for you so I
hope you have a great rest of your day
and hey Happy New Year whoo
[Music]